i scored it took me 42 years to find the
right person
you know jonathan scott is not shy about
declaring his love for girlfriend zoe
deschanel
and now they're mixing work and play on
his show celebrity iou and
only e.t had a chance to sit down with
zoe to talk about their collaboration
both on screen and off
jonathan said you make him the best
version of himself
what do you do to make him the best
version of himself i just cook him
food he likes does he do the same for
you
yes he absolutely makes me the best
version of myself
makes me feel so happy he's just the
most wonderful person
i'm so lucky i love that i can be
nerdy and romantic with her and she
kicks it back to me in exactly the same
amount of
you know romanticism and comedy we just
enjoy spending every moment with each
other
it's been 15 months and zoe and jonathan
are going strong
they even moved in together doing the
pandemic it's been
nice actually to be quarantined together
he had a checklist of
stuff he was going to do around the
house so so nice
also scoring jonathan some pretty major
brownie points
he's helping zoe surprise her lifelong
friend sarah with a home makeover
on tonight's season 2 premiere of
celebrity iou
surprise surprise how did this come
about how did the negotiation go
the negotiation while jonathan was like
do you want to do this thing and i was
like yeah
i've been friends with her since we were
five so i have a daughter who's five so
when i see her i think oh my gosh we're
like sisters she's like my sister
i was in her wedding i sang in her
wedding you sang in her wedding pregnant
right yup i was eight months pregnant
when i sang
bye drew bye bye these two
are so adorable makes me sick she's
amazing when we were working together we
were laughing like a bunch of idiots
the whole time i just don't think this
is my thing
the worst part for me is that it's loud
you were not into the demo were you i
know i hate
now i hate it could you do this again oh
my god i could i love it it's so fun
i know jonathan has joked that you and
drew's wife could become the property
sisters
we we definitely like love design this
is jimmy and dave the real estate
brothers
also appearing this season the office
star rayne wilson
allison janney and justin hartley
everyone knows justin from this is us
and he's an amazing actor and he's
honestly just a great down-to-earth guy
there is a little moment
in that episode where somebody fully
clothed
gets thrown into the pool that was the
one bone i had to pick with justin
i don't like it when somebody has more
abs than i have on hairs on my head like
it's just not fair